[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
avec les beaux jours on recommence la
valse des records sur les stades
d'athlétisme une valse qui prend la
tournure d'un feu d'artifice pour les
sauteurs à la perche américaine a
Philadelphie Steinberg et le premier
athlète à franchir les 5 mètres mais
Steinberg ignorait que son triomphe
serait de courte durée trois jours plus
tard son compatriotes John Pennel
franchissait 5m04 l'émulation aidant ils
finiront par aller dans la Lune vous
verrez
de son côté l'athlète de Formose young
Shui a crevé le plafond du décathlon le
décathlon c'est l'épreuve des hommes qui
savent tout faire courir sauter ou bien
lancer un poids un javelot ou un disque
sait faire tout cela et comme il le fait
bien il a pulvérisé le record du monde
il a même en passant essayé de faire
mieux que Sternberg à la perche mais là
il a échoué il faut bien laisser
quelques records aux autres tout de même
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
les redoutable Camille Casey japonais
c'était promis de torpiller comme de
vulgaires croiseurs de bataille les
catcheurs mondiaux les plus réputés ici
Gilbert Leduc et Jacky corne
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
dès les premiers échanges la fourberie
des catcheurs suicides s'étale au grand
jour
et seul un sursaut désespéré sauvera le
français d'une infamante d'État
d'asiate dont l'un ici va faire passer à
son adversaire un désagréable quart
d'heure qui aurait pu être le dernier si
le renfort attendu avec quelques peu
tardé
dans un climat passionné le représentant
de l'Occident va faire mieux que saint
Michel en terrassant successivement les
deux dragons et notre justicier envoie
le kamikaze faire un magistral piqué
dans l'océan des fauteuils d'orchestre
Blanchette japonaise pour le Nippon
sérieusement malmené et le français
écarte définitivement le péril en
descendant en flamme l'orgueilleux
kamikaze
akicorne et Gilbert Leduc vainqueur
cette fois c'est le bon départ
la grande mutation qui a ramené les
bourgeons sur les branches les citadins
à la campagne candide à son jardin et
Mimi Pinson à sa fenêtre c'est
l'explosion de toute la nature qui a
fait refleurir jusqu'au plat de vente de
Jean Barthès le melon et le canotier
tiennent le haut du châssis avec la
cloche fleurie comme un pommier du Japon
autant de petits jardins gracieusement
suspendus dans le mois babylonien des
décors
[Musique]
l'un s'appelle rue du soleil tout un
programme l'autre rue de Bourgogne comme
l'hôtel dans lequel monsieur de
bergeracuttin duel rapprochement gratuit
car le fond attire moins l'épée que les
fléchettes
[Musique]
je suis tweet voyez mon grain éternel
féminin changeante et illusoire
[Musique]
je suis broderie anglaise je suis
capeline voyez mes bords éternel féminin
fantasque et versatile je suis toc
il tourne les têtes et retourne les
chapeaux c'est le printemps
i comme chaque année les forts des
Halles leur reine et ses demoiselles
d'honneur sont venus offrir au président
de la République et à Madame De Gaulle
le muguet du 1er mai un 1er mai dont le
général de Gaulle a dit qu'il était
faite du printemps fête du Travail et
fête de la paix
[Musique]
à Moscou le 1er mai a pris la forme
habituelle du défilé de masse sur la
Place Rouge il a constitué pour l'autre
de Monsieur crotchav Fidel Castro le
point culminant d'un séjour uniformément
triomphale
la présence du président cubain dans la
tribune officielle a eu entre autres
conséquences celle de provoquer
l'absence des représentants de
l'ambassade des États-Unis
[Musique]
un 1er mai moscovite en tout point égal
à sa tradition
[Musique]
nelle aussi le premier mai à Pékin à
ceci près qu'il n'y avait pas de
personnalité de la taille de Fidel
Castro à offrir à la foule chinoise
les dirigeants de la Chine populaire ont
participé à l'immense kermesse qui est
ici la fête du travail au milieu de 4
millions d'habitants
amené par l'ancien yacht du roi Farouk
qui porte aujourd'hui le nom de liberté
le président Gamal Abdel Nasser a rendu
sa première visite à Alger
après la fin de la guerre d'Algérie la
population de la capitale a réservé avec
Monsieur Benbella un accueille
enthousiaste à celui que l'on appelait
le grand frère
[Applaudissements]
accueille si enthousiaste que les deux
hommes dure abandonné leur automobile
pour une voiture de pompier afin
d'achever la traversée de la ville le
drapeau de la République Arabe unique
comptera-t-il un jour 5 étoiles la
cinquième représentant l'Algérie
conférence interafricaine d'avis abbeva
problème des regroupements en cours au
Proche-Orient tels allaient être les
principaux thèmes des entretiens
politiques des deux hommes d'État
capable de transporter dans ses soutes 8
à 15 tonnes de fret d'une remarquable
maniabilité telle est le nouvel appareil
de transport militaire que Monsieur
Messmer ministre des Armées et Monsieur
fanassel son collègue de l'Allemagne
fédéral en vue décoller en 200 mètres
sur le terrain d'Istres fruits de la
coopération franco-allemande le Transall
C160 qui effectuait son premier vol
public cette affaire le luxe de
plusieurs passages suivi de virages en S
avec un moteur arrêté
[Musique]
ce wagon de chemin de fer volant peut
franchir 4500 km à une vitesse de
croisière de 500 km heure
[Musique]
qui n'a pas vu la route à l'aube toute
fraîche toute vivante ne sait pas ce que
c'est que l'espérance cette pensée de
Bernanos a sans doute soutenue la
plupart des 9000 étudiants en rupture de
laboratoire et d'amphithéâtre qui ont
participé aux traditionnels pèlerinages
de charme
cette traversée de la Beauce a été une
épreuve volontaire pour ses modernes
croisés partie de Rambouillet et
dépernon ils avaient retrouvé à travers
les blés naissants les traces et la foi
des pèlerins de jadis
mais 50 km de marche pour des jeunes
gens et des jeunes filles non entraînés
nécessité à l'étape quelques réconforts
tandis que les confessions redonnaient
leur vrai sens à cette marge vers la
lumière
[Musique]
et c'est avec une joie sans mélange que
les jeunes pèlerins en vue enfin surgir
la flèche irréprochable
[Musique]